Ці фото в червні облетіли український інтернет.
В Одесі двоє невідомих у масках
напали на 49-ти річну громадську активістку
Світлану Подпалу та жорстоко її побили.
Це змусило мене переосмислити ситуацію в нашому місті.
Я зрозуміла, що в нас дійсно діє добре озброєне,
добре оснащене злочинне угрупування.
Світлана не очікувала такої радикальної реакції
на діяльність її громадського руху "Зелений лист",
який вона з однодумцями створила два роки тому.
Сьогодні це майже 100 активістів, які проводять мітинги
проти вирубки зелених зон. Проти комунальників,
через недогляд яких гинуть дерева. Борються за збереження
історичних катакомб, над якими зводять багатоповерхівки.
Відстоюють пляжі й узбережжя від рейдерських захоплень.
Світлана веде власні розслідування зловживань та корупції,
подає скарги, пише викривальні статті, створюючи
суспільний резонанс. Вона не боїться називати речі
своїми іменами й оприлюднювати інформацію про тих,
хто стоїть за цими діями. Своїм головним ворогом
вважає міську владу, яка, як вважає Світлана,
своїми новими приписами фактично дозволила
знищувати унікальне середмістя Одеси.
Я хочу добитися, щоб вони припинили знищувати,
спотворювати моє улюблене місто. Життя в Одесі
стає нестерпним для її мешканців. Про це говорять усі -
що треба або якусь анестезію моральну мати,
щоб на це не звертати уваги,
або кудись виїжджати.
У "Зеленого листа" немає фінансування для боротьби з можновладцями.
Головна зброя Світлани - слово.
Філолог за освітою вона багато працювала в ЗМІ,
видавництвах, правозахисних організаціях.
Головна моя зброя - це думка, втілена у плакаті.
З одного боку, це доходить до людей.
З іншого - дуже дратує міську владу.
Після побиття Світлана зрозуміла, що «дратувати» можновладців
в Одесі стає дедалі небезпечніше.
Вона не вірить в те, що розслідування, яке веде поліція,
встановить виконавців і замовників.
Та зупинятися не збирається. Заради майбутнього своїх дітей
і заради городян, які її підтримують.
Багато хто мені каже: «Продовжуй! Нам так подобається дивитися,
як ти борешся! Ми тебе підтримаємо,
Особиста ініціатива рідко зустрічається.
І тому я завжди намагаюся підштовхнути людей,
надихнути їх, сказати, що ти можеш сам.
Для себе таке натхнення Світлана знайшла під час Революції Гідності.
До того  вона навіть не думала, що колись займатиметься
громадською діяльністю. Планувала більше часу проводити з дітьми.
Та вийшло навпаки - роботи стало ще більше.
Зате діти ростуть свідомими одеситами
і мама для них - приклад для наслідування.
Інші люди цього не розуміють,
поки їх це особисто не зачепить… Важко захищати місто,
але це треба робити.
Світлана розчарувалася у місцевій владі і не вірить,
що після нових виборів щось зміниться. Тож, сенсу
йти в політику не бачить. Вважає, що більше зможе
досягти громадською діяльністю, залучаючи до неї
дедалі більше однодумців, які прагнуть бачити Одесу
по-справжньому європейським містом.